If you're looking for a fun and cheap way
to watch events like the Superbowl or March
Madness, here's a low budget life hack that
will convert your laptop, smartphone, or tablet
into an improvised home-theatre!
I started this project with a cardboard box,
and a roll of duct-tape. I got the black kind.
Aside from those, the only other thing we'll
need is a simple magnifying lens. I got this
one online for about $4 with free shipping.
These are typically sold as full page magnifiers
for reading small text. The end of this cardboard box is just slightly bigger than the plastic
lens. So let's place it in the middle, and
when it looks about center, we can trace around
the edges. Now the lens is gonna be taped
to the inside of this box, so let's trace
out another set of lines about 1/2" smaller,
and now the setup should look like this. While
we're here, let's use a credit card or hotel
key to trace out a rectangle in the center.
Alright, it's time to get to work making some
cuts, and scissors can be a little awkward,
so I'm gonna try using this steak knife
instead. Let's start by cutting out the center
piece, taking time to make the cuts as clean
as possible. Now we'll need to cut along the
inside edges, and if you've done it right
you should be left with a piece that looks
like this, but don't throw it away. Now this
part is optional, but I'm gonna add some
duct-tape along the cut edges just to smooth
them over and clean up the look. Now let's
flip the box over to expose the inside, and
add our lens. This gets placed over the hole
with the grooved side facing up. Some more
duct-tape is added to secure the lens in position,
and now we can work on making the box a little
more sturdy. I'm folding the big bottom flaps
in first, so that the smaller flaps are on
the outside. A strip of tape will ensure the
inside bottom is flat and smooth, and the
outside flaps are taped down as well. Next,
let's use our knife to cut down the two corners
at the back to make a flap that opens up.
The top can now be closed, and tape used to
hold everything together firm and strong.
I gave mine a quick paint job, and there's
the finished projector.
Well, that was cheap and easy.
Ok we're gonna need a projection screen,
so I went to a sign supply company and found
this sheet of 0.02 hi-impact styrene for about
$2. The sheet is 4 feet wide and adding a
little black duct-tape to the edges gives
it a nice looking border. I had just enough
tape left to hang the screen on the wall,
and rig up a make-shift theatre room. Now
this lens configuration will allow the most
light to shine through, but if your okay with a
darker but crisper image, you can go ahead
and add the shroud to the front of the lens.
This will tighten the aperture and give a
better focus. At this point we're about ready
to test it out. I'm gonna try it with this
iPad, and we'll need to go into the settings
menu and make sure we lock the rotation of
the screen. We'll also need to bring the light
up to maximum. To hold your tablet upright
in the projector, you'll need to find something
sturdy. This box of tomato paste was the right
size for me, so I used a couple of rubber
bands to hold the iPad firmly against the
box and with the screen flipped upside down.
This can be slid into the projector, and
you may need to play around with the positing
of your tablet to see where it focuses the
best. Ok let's turn off the lights and test
it out.
Well there you go. We just made a
cheap version of a 50" home theatre, and it
looks pretty decent.
If you try this with your smartphone, the
process is pretty much the same, but your
picture will be a little smaller. I found
that a laptop computer gives the best results
because it's got the brightest screen. It
fits together a little differently, but works
for all the same reasons. So if you're trying
to save money there's a little trick that
will hopefully keep costs low, and put a fun
spin on your next sports party. If you liked
this project, perhaps you'll like some of
my others. Check them out at www.thekingofrandom.com